Let me read this CNN headline to you.
Navajo Nation's
objection to Landing Human Remains
on the moon prompts last minute
White House meeting.
Now, to understand this, here's
what you need to know.
There are companies that will, for fee.
Fly your cremated remains to space.
In this case, bury them on the moon.
Two private companies
that provide these lunar burial
services, Celestis and Elysium Space
plan to send dozens of sets of human
remains on a lunar lander
set to launch on Monday.
But the president of the Navajo
Nation says that turning the moon
into a burial ground
would be offensive
to indigenous cultures.
They've asked the White House and NASA
to delay the launch
And consider
this, that NASA apologized
for doing something similar.
More than 20 years ago,
in a statement,
the CEO of Celestis says
they reject the concerns.
The flight desecrates the moon.
It is a touching and fitting celebration,
he says.
For our participants,
the exact opposite of desecration,
it is a celebration.
Joining me
now is the president of the Navajo
Nation, Dr. Boot Nygren.
Mr.
President, thank you for being with me.
Let me start here
with just the explanation of why sending
these human remains,
these capsules with DNA to the moon
would be considered
by the Navajo Nation and others
a desecration of the moon.
Good morning.
I appreciate
the time that you all have given me.
One of the first things,
as I explained,
we had a last minute meeting
with the White House, NASA
and Department of Transportation
officials yesterday.
And one of the things I explained to them
yesterday was that to over 20 years ago,
you guys made a promise
that after the fact that you set
to the remains of an astronaut into space
and onto the moon,
that you promised to make sure
that you can sort this into the future.
But through the discussions yesterday,
through the
through the loopholes
of private companies
that they can don't have to consult us.
But they did promise
that moving into the future,
that they would consult us.
And one of the things I asked them
is that you guys have a lot of influence
as far as NASA.
Most of these missions won't happen
without the funding,
the millions of dollars
that help you launch these projects.
So you should have a say in
trying to make sure that the
that the promises that were made
over 20 years ago are upheld.
That's the logistics of this.
But first,
what is the cultural significance?
What is what is the the deeply
and profoundly, as you've said it,
disappointing desecration.
If these remains were to go to the moon.
One of the first and for a Navajo
medicine man is called Hattersley
and they
they practice for many, many years.
I just want to be upfront.
I'm not a medicine man,
but one of the things that our elders
and our across,
these are medicine
People have told me that
the moon is sacred.
It's in our songs, it's
in our stories, it's in our creation.
We use the moon as a place
that we've looked to
for hundreds of years
to make sure that we continue to exist.
So they're part of ceremonies
that have been around
with the Navajo people
for a long, long time.
So when this happened in the
in the nineties,
it was very clear
that we should make sure that we consult
our medicine people,
consult the Navajo people
before we do something like that.
The Navajo Nation
has never been opposed to exploration
or curiosity or space missions.
It's just the fact that
the uniqueness of life is so important
that there's only one place,
no matter how far
into the universe we look,
we have looked for decades now.
Now, with the technologies that we have,
we haven't found human beings.
We haven't found another place
like Earth.
So to us,
it's we're very unique,
were created here on Earth,
and we should continue to exist
here on Earth
as we move along out of this life.
So that's one of the things
that have that
the medicine men have told us.
And then the fact that
they're ceremonies
that continue to exist here
within the Navajo Nation
and across
all indigenous cultures
that have looked to the skies for air
for for for thousands of years,
and just to know to know
that you have human remains
circling the earth,
that's a little concerning
to think about,
because a lot of us pray to the moon,
pray to the moon,
and that's the female counterpart of the
sun in our culture. Mm hmm.
You say that you were part
of this meeting
with NASA
and the Department
of Transportation,
Commerce Department,
FAA, other officials,
the private company as well.
What came out of this meeting?
Can you tell us more about it?
Will the launch be delayed?
I believe it was a meeting to kind of
softly tell us that, you know what,
we're sorry,
but the launch is still going to happen.
But one of the things that I requested
is that we should have
there's going to be a lot more,
as you mentioned earlier,
throughout this year.
And we
and we only ask
that NASA fulfill
its part of its promise.
And one of the
I had a discussion after the meeting
with the NASA administrator, Mr.
Nelson, and he did say,
you know, I support you, Mr.
President,
but in return, I did ask him,
we should sit down and talk about that.
If NASA's going to be
a part of any mission
they should fulfill,
even if it's a private company,
because most of these private companies
would probably not launch into space
without the dollars
that come along
with partnering with NASA.
So one of the things I ask is
if NASA's going to be a part of it,
they should just have strict guidelines
that said,
you know what, We have a promise
with indigenous people
that exist in the United States
that we're not going to
we're going to consult them
and that we're going to make sure
that human remains don't go into space.
And I hope that those discussions
actually come to fruition.
Yeah, that commitment was made
back in the nineties
after a human remains were sent to
the moon.
A president of the Navajo Nation, Dr.
Bill Nygren,
thank you so much for being with me.
Thank you, sir.